[inaudible].
Hi everybody.
Welcome.
Welcome to David Cross.
And Amy said,
Doris,
I'm cliff longer already.
I work in the toxic Google program.
Thank you so much for being here.
Thanks for having a handrail.
Yeah.
So if you actually,
if you saw the film yesterday,
which I know we had a screening last night,
please do.
We asked,
just know,
like live tweeting of spoilers or anything as the film was not yet available.
So we want to make sure that that is something we take care of.
But that said,
we are here to talk about hits,
which is written and directed by David and starring Amy starring snoring.
So,
uh,
honestly,
let's just look at the sign for a second as I do love the tagline based on a
true story that hasn't happened yet.
Now,
if you've seen the film,
I might argue that it may have happened.
Well,
yeah,
there's a not to give,
uh,
one of the spoilers out,
but one of the things we,
that's in the film,
uh,
actually did happen roughly four months after we were at Sundance.
It was a national story.
I can't say it otherwise.
It'll,
but you know what I'm talking about.
So I felt very vindicated.
Um,
but that's just one aspect of this story that's happened and I'm sure it's
happened in Florida or perhaps happening as we speak.
Um,
that's said.
So what inspired you to write this particular story?
Uh,
and when did you write it?
I wrote it in June of 82 and a very,
very precious ahead of my time.
I had been reading a lot h g wells and I'm,
no,
I wrote it,
uh,
the,
the inspiration for this particular,
there's two parts to this answer.
One is I was at a Sundance festival a couple of years ago and,
um,
I saw two particularly egregious indie films that,
uh,
bothered me in different ways.
Um,
one was just kind of an eye rolly like boring plodding movie where nothing
happened,
but it ticked all the indie film boxes.
A,
I'm sure there was Glockenspiel in there at some point.
And,
um,
and then I saw a movie right after that,
like the,
the next day that really I hated and it was just fraudulent bullshit.
And,
uh,
and it was being celebrated at a,
at the film for a festival for Indie film.
And,
um,
uh,
and then I was complaining about it and I thought,
all right,
enough,
you know,
uh,
I should put my money where my mouth is.
If the,
if these things bother me,
go make your own fucking movie that you like,
you know,
and uh,
and quit bitching about other people's stuff.
I mean,
that's what critics do.
Um,
uh,
they don't actually create things,
I'm sorry,
they just tear them down.
But uh,
uh,
so just don't do that.
Go actually make something.
And then the re the second part of that answer is because of all the ideas I
kind of have floating around on little pieces of scratch paper on my desk.
Uh,
this is the one I,
I could shoot the cheapest,
which meant I had the better,
better possible.
You know,
there was a greater possibility of getting it made.
So I figured,
cause I live not too far from liberty.
Have a place up there and uh,
and a lot of the people,
you seem packed,
the waitress,
a friend of mine who's a at Baker's tap where your character works,
that's her bar and that's the bar I go to my wife and I go and a m.
So it was calling it a lot of favors and a,
and I stayed at my place,
people crashing my house and you know,
so that was the reason for this particular idea.
Oh Wow.
Very nice.
All right.
We done.
Yeah.
So speaking of making the film,
you use Kickstarter in order to fund part of the film?
No.
Uh,
we use Kickstarter to distribute it.
Okay.
Uh,
we had made the film,
we went,
uh,
we were at Sundance,
which was,
uh,
a immeasurably helpful for the life of the film.
Uh,
uh,
and we got some offers,
you know,
you,
I'm not that well versed in the business end of things.
And that's partly by choice.
I know it's a,
it's probably stupid on my part,
but I just don't follow numbers and things like that.
And I don't,
I don't care to,
but,
uh,
you know,
we,
the producers hired a sales agent in the,
and this is standard for any movies at festivals.
You hire a sales agent,
the sales agent acts on your behalf to talk to the distributors who've made
offers.
And they do this all without,
you know,
I'm not privy to that stuff.
And,
uh,
and sales agents are one of those businesses that are so numerous in America
where somebody just invents their own reason to exist and then now you have to
use them because that's this standard,
you know?
Um,
and so the,
the,
but their best,
their interests are,
and about the film or getting it to as many people as possible,
their interest is as getting as much money as possible.
And I don't give a shit about that.
And so the producers,
we got very standard,
uh,
distribution,
plans for,
for a movie like this,
uh,
a low budget indie movie with no big bankable stars.
And it was la per week.
New York.
No.
And we got,
uh,
you know,
La for a week,
New York per week,
and then maybe Chicago and a handful of other cities and then straight to VOD
and apples,
apples,
apples.
I,
how old am I
right.
Turns on apples
and your Google play of course.
That's terrific.
No,
I don't know what Google is.
I,
uh,
I've seen the sign everywhere.
You know,
your font is complete,
your colors are off.
Anyway.
Um,
uh,
I would like somebody here though to explain to me how to get the Google ad
things
off my Gmail and it just constantly coming up.
Well,
there will be a Q and a later,
which we'll have David asked the questions and you guys can answer ads for Uber.
She's a reprehensible company and a,
and I keep getting ads for them on my phone and like,
what if I die?
And somebody was like,
oh,
he's in an Uber.
No.
Anyway,
we need to bring that back around.
You mentioned having the most amount of people see this film.
So one of the ways you're doing that,
it's releasing it on bit torrent,
a bit torrent.
Vhx
uh,
and,
and then,
you know,
that's,
that's a,
uh,
a great way to get as many people to see it as possible.
And that,
and the producers were the ones who came up with that idea.
Um,
but I was also,
uh,
you know,
I want people to see it in the theater.
I think it's a,
a vastly different experience watching a film in the dark,
uninterrupted,
no cell phone,
no pets or kids or phones or,
or any outside disturbance,
you know,
it's a different experience.
And,
um,
and when we're kind of losing that,
uh,
and so,
my,
so we started a Kickstarter campaign to get it into as many theaters as possible
and now it's going to be in a 50 theaters,
theaters who would never,
ever,
ever play in ever.
And,
um,
uh,
and I learned about,
I didn't know about three rivers,
Michigan,
never heard of it before,
but now I do because it's going to play there tonight.
Um,
you're also having a pay as you go format.
pay what you want,
pay as you go well,
cause then we lock you in unless you paid to leave.
Um,
uh,
but,
pay as you go.
You're not staying in this theater for a week,
young man,
until you can get some money from somewhere and you'll be able to see all these
first one films.
Sure.
We didn't think this out thoroughly,
but,
um,
uh,
yeah,
so it's pay what you want because you know,
we use
Kickstarter funds to go and rent the theaters and paper the staff and all that
stuff.
And um,
and you know,
uh,
to,
to supplement it.
We use Kickstarter.
So hopefully we'll be able to offset some of our costs were by people pitching
in whatever they want.
But,
um,
but the idea was just to get it in as many theaters and in front of as many
people as possible.
That's why I made the film not to make $100,000 from,
you know,
IFC films or whatever.
Just don't,
not that they just use them as an example.
But
so as a now a feature director,
would you do it again?
Absolutely not.
No,
no.
Yeah,
it was great.
it was fun.
And it would your work with David?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Thanks.
It was,
he was a great director,
but he kept encouraging you to make stuff up,
you know,
improvise.
You're saying what you want,
you know,
you know what's on the page.
But for me,
when I take the time to memorize something,
I'm so proud of myself that I know every word that I,
sometimes I can't get that out of my head,
you know what I mean?
And I'm an,
I am an improviser,
so I,
but I,
for this,
you know,
I don't think I improvised anything.
It was just also,
it was great and I got to work with Meredith.
You Find Meredith,
by the way,
that was a casting,
cause the,
the girl who was going to play Meredith,
um,
backed out about a month before we were supposed to start shooting it.
You know,
that's,
uh,
it really fucks you up.
It's a,
it was a,
uh,
that was tough and we thought we were going to lose some of our investors,
investor money and stuff and it was really not cool.
Um,
so then we had a scramble and I went out to La and,
uh,
do you know Gina Mccarthy?
Yup.
Yeah.
So Jeannie,
I called genie and was like,
I've got an emergency.
Here's this script.
I sent it to her and,
and she,
cause I don't know,
young girls,
I don't know or I don't know that,
you know what I mean?
I don't know that world.
I don't,
uh,
restraining order.
I'm not allowed to,
but I don't know that everybody else in the film are friends of mine.
And,
uh,
and I,
you know,
called Amy and called,
Matt and Dave and all those people and uh,
and they were like,
yeah,
sounds great,
but I just don't know.
And,
and Jake who's place,
uh,
Corey,
I dunno,
he's 16.
And,
uh,
so Jenny McCarthy set up a couple of weekends sessions and I flew out to La and
we read a lot of people.
And then,
um,
and then I kept going back to Meredith who had gotten the script,
couldn't be in la,
so sent an audition,
like read the lines,
had somebody hold an iPhone.
Um,
and she was awesome.
She was great.
And,
uh,
I kept,
she was like one of my first choices.
I kept coming back to her,
but that was reading people live and we'd have callbacks and then a third round
of callbacks for like winnow it down to like three or four people.
And,
and I just kept going back to Meredith and,
uh,
um,
and my wife,
who's in the business was very instrumental and going,
you got to,
you got to give her the opportunity to come in live.
And so I flew back to New York because she was here.
And I asked UCB for their theater for a couple hours in a red her and,
and my wife,
uh,
read along.
And,
um,
uh,
and then literally there were a couple of women who were on the east coast that
I couldn't see.
So,
uh,
who were there and then we just knew it was Meredith.
So that's,
I'd never heard of her before.
She,
I think she did soap operas.
Right.
But it was great working with her because,
you know,
she gave it her all.
So it was easy to,
to the expression because I'm like,
what are you doing?
Are you doing this more?
I mean,
she was doing,
she just did it.
It gave 100%.
So it was fun to be in scenes with her cause I just felt like she was,
she really was that character.
But you,
so you didn't improvise at all,
do you?
I don't think so.
Maybe a word here and there,
but no,
and I just had a tooth pulled and it was a death in my family,
so it wa I wasn't up to par.
Which one was worse.
Ooh.
Um,
but it also,
when I read the script,
which I thought,
I mean I laugh when I got the script by laughter when everything down that made
me laugh.
I,
it was hilarious.
But you know,
at Burton when I said that my character would eat Doritos,
I was like,
I can't do the to be,
I can't eat Doritos.
I just want to take a poll,
we can find something else saying me.
So he gave me marshmallows,
which was great because then it gets stuck in line,
missing tooth and it was very comfortable.
Perfect size
fee.
That's something could get stuck in a missing too.
I mean just had to teach you just went through the experience and stitches.
It seems like every time I do a movie of stitches in my mouth.
Okay.
No it was over a year and a half.
I had 44 total stitches I think.
Oh my God.
Terrible.
Yeah.
So that's fine.
I'm a first generation American British,
so
DNA is not good.
You mentioned Amy that a,
you had to,
uh,
you did not improvise a lot,
but is that how you'd like to work as an actor,
David,
to have?
I do.
And,
and,
uh,
um,
I mean in the way,
any anytime or any project I've done,
uh,
I've always cast with an eye towards people who are skilled or adept at,
improvising because I think you just find parts of your character that,
that maybe I as the writer having discovered and there and there,
it's really cool and it,
and it opens up all new worlds.
And,
uh,
um,
and I can't help but improvise sometimes,
especially if I know that the,
they've got what they wanted that was on the page and,
uh,
it's almost like Tourette's from me.
They just can't,
I'm doing scenes and I can't not do it.
And,
uh,
um,
I mean,
we,
we did that a lot on the,
we shot a pilot.
Uh,
we got to work together on this pilot that,
that didn't go.
Um,
but we had a couple of scenes and we were improvising all over the place.
You just can't.
And it's such a joy.
It's a fucking treat.
And it's the thing I missed about acting in this,
like especially the scenes in the diner,
um,
uh,
a number of which aren't in the film,
the,
there'll be in the extras just because they were too funny and it fucked up the
flow of it.
But,
um,
uh,
I so wanted to get in there and just be,
you know,
just want to play,
you want to play.
It's really frustrating not to do that and just sit behind the thing.
But I laughed a lot and uh,
uh,
yeah,
I mean I always,
I always liked to make sure we get what's on the page,
what's necessary and then just have fun.
And we,
we,
we do Todd,
Margaret and I tell the directors,
I,
you know,
that shot,
you want that really cool shot from up there where it kind of pushes in,
but it's like a rack focus thing from the top of the roof that's going to take
an hour to set up,
lose it.
Because I'd rather spend that hour,
you know,
with the actors finding shit.
It's much more valuable to me
and Ian Design everything.
Like at one in the bar scene that someone had made de Martini,
but they put like an orange and umbrella and a cherry.
I don't know if you remember that,
but you immediately saw to the lens and you were like,
get that thing out of there.
Who did this?
You know,
and you would scratch it.
But I always said,
oh,
that's good.
You really paid attention to those little details,
lived there.
I wouldn't,
uh,
um,
I mean that's,
you know,
that's their job is to come the set director to do the right stuff,
but it's just not,
yeah,
it wasn't right for the scene.
It's called a flag.
By the way,
bartenders,
if there are any,
uh,
would be bartenders here.
So as a director,
writer,
actor,
stand up,
what's your favorite of the jobs
craft services?
I do.
I'm the guy who puts
the peanut butter filling into the pretzels,
the nuggets.
And um,
and I,
I studied for two years abroad and a bra outside a factory outside of Beijing to
learn how to do that.
And it is a treat.
Um,
and you see the people's faces light up when you get that Costco Tub and you
then in the bowl of chowder.
It's so good.
So good.
I how was crest services on own budget?
How many raisins can you like?
It was a really tiny wonder over here has the delicious,
so I actually,
I did one of the few things you can control and I know this from,
from,
you know,
uh,
working in front of the camera on so many low budget things.
One of the things I knew as a producer that I,
I could control was catering and I,
and I said to them early before we started shooting,
like,
let's find some extra money,
a little bit extra money to make catering good so that it doesn't suck because
we're asking these people to work really hard lugging around cables and setting
up lights.
It's in the summer and nobody's getting paid anything six day weeks,
you know,
just make sure you have a good lunch.
It makes a huge difference.
And the hotel had a radio that was nice.
It said radio when everyone
was like,
why does it smell like chlorine?
There's no pool.
Ended up radio only played the Casey.
Casey was top 40,
from 1987.
Bless his heart.
It's on a loop.
I have a green.
You have any questions in house?
If you do,
there's two microphones in both the aisles.
A I'll call on you if you're up there.
Just want to let you guys know.
I'm so liberty New York,
it's a,
the reason you've actually filmed everything in house as you said.
Um,
it's where you're living up there.
I don't live in La,
right?
Really?
I live in a town about 22 minutes roughly.
Boy,
that is roughly,
it's exact,
uh,
roughly 22 minutes,
17 seconds.
Uh,
the little town dividing line.
Um,
no,
I live,
yeah,
20,
25 minutes away.
So,
uh,
or have a place up there.
And um,
uh,
but when we were scouting like liberty and I just on my own,
actually before this,
there were producers involved when I was looking.
Uh,
I mean,
all the stuff you see in the movie,
all that signage that's real,
that's there,
that's in liberty,
uh,
tons of American flags in,
in various forms of,
uh,
of,
you know,
from new to ratty and torn.
But,
uh,
um,
it's,
you couldn't,
I mean,
he can't,
that's a lot of production value.
That's,
that's essentially for free,
you know,
and I even toyed with calling the movie liberty for a little while,
but liberty would have been good.
I like hits though.
It's Kinda perfect.
Hits has the double meaning,
which I like.
So,
yeah.
All right.
So,
um,
in addition to this film,
I know everyone here wants to hear your talk about some other things,
so if you don't mind,
I just wanted to ask you what it feels like to be as busy as you must be
considering Todd Margaret arrested development,
which is something that sounds everyone's mind.
If there's going to be another season,
if there's going to be the,
I haven't heard a thing about it.
Uh,
and not that that's out of the ordinary.
I mean usually,
uh,
Jason was really good about keeping everybody linkedin.
Um,
which would be a great name for a website that would allow like that down.
Will you bing and see if this
person,
uh,
no,
I don't know.
I haven't heard anything.
I Know Mitch is busy.
I know will's doing this other thing.
The thing about arrested that was so difficult was it,
and I don't think people understand this.
Like when it's a studio and you're doing a show,
you're all these people are hired for that set period of time.
And we weren't and it didn't go that way.
Otherwise,
every and between a third and a half of the cast lives in New York,
you know,
and uh,
you would have to bring her buddy out there and give him a,
you know,
if he didn't live there like a stipend to,
to put them up in hotels or whatever it is.
And um,
and that's where you are and you're paid to be there for eight months to shoot
it.
And they didn't do that.
And so there was a,
it got spread out for a much longer than than we thought it would.
And we were getting calls,
all of us,
you know,
uh,
yeah,
I know we just sent you home,
but can he come back Tuesday for a scene?
You know,
stuff like that.
And uh,
that was spread out over,
um,
over a year,
well over a year,
year and a half.
Um,
and so that makes it really,
really difficult and everybody's so busy.
But I can't say that I,
I think I speak for everybody that we would love to do something again.
It's a really,
nobody is a unaware or unappreciative of how special that show is and how much
fun it is and how universally loved it is a,
except in Nigeria.
Fuck them.
But it's such a fun character.
Do great people to play with and great writing.
So,
you know,
but I haven't heard anything at all.
Sorry,
one more.
The rumors about Mr Show.
I,
uh,
Bob and I are working together to work together.
We have been meeting for about a month now.
A little over a month.
I'll fly out to la for a week.
I buy care fly back there though,
you know,
um,
and been writing stuff.
I've gotten together with the other writers and we,
I cannot say specifically what we're going to be doing,
but we will be doing something.
We're very excited about it.
Uh,
it won't be Mr Show per se,
but it will be a sketch show that Bob and I,
you know,
same sensibilities,
same hopefully same group of people and a look for it in a TB bucks soon ish.
Yeah.
And then with one than I've always wanted to work in London.
And is it really different to,
to shoot something there like the post to the United States?
Like what's the difference?
Uh,
I,
I have not noticed the accent difference at all.
Everybody keeps mentioning it.
Um,
it's,
uh,
it's a little less,
um,
and this is both good and bad,
but it's a little less.
Um,
it's,
it's definitely more,
uh,
people don't give a shit.
There's no,
uh,
this idea of like locking down streets unless you're this massive budgeted,
you know,
if it's Sherlock or Harry Potter or something.
Yeah.
Of course he can lock down streaks,
but you know,
it just,
you just,
it's not like New York or la when you're,
when you get a big police presence that allows you to shoot the thing.
And we with Todd,
Margaret,
our budget's so low and we have to steal so much shit.
In fact,
we were shooting,
we were shooting a scene in front of a,
it was in the first series and it's when I'm first going to the pub with Sharon
Horgan Alice,
and we're shooting this thing and this guy walks up the street,
this,
uh,
like 55 60 year old black guy.
And he comes up and he sees the camera and he's like,
hey.
And he tips his hat.
And he had,
and uh,
he starts talking to us and it was just like,
that's,
it's not like they don't care.
There's no like,
oh,
you don't,
you don't instinctively go,
I'd better cross the street.
Or,
um,
uh,
it just,
they don't care.
And the,
the positive side of that is I've,
I'll go to us,
there's a couple different pubs here that a lot of the comic community,
uh,
Goto and um,
there's one,
especially in Dean Street and it's a small pub and you go and you're sitting
there,
you're like,
Holy Shit,
I'm sitting there with these comedy gods and everybody's having drinking.
Nobody gives a shit.
You know,
I was having a drink with Simon Pegg.
Nobody gave a fuck.
And,
and you don't get that here.
People are like,
oh my God.
Yeah.
But did you,
and did you like living there?
I love it.
Yeah.
I,
I'm really,
I really like it and I,
if it's,
it gets very lonely for me if my wife's not there and,
uh,
um,
you know,
especially,
work is great,
but at the end of the day,
everybody's got families or partners that they go back to and then you're just
sort of sitting there.
Sometimes they'll throw you a bone,
they can tell you're lonely and they'll have a few drinks with you at a pub,
but then they got to get back and everybody,
you know,
it's public transportation is,
is,
uh,
prevalent,
but it's a bit of a mess and can be,
and,
uh,
you know,
in London is really spread out.
So you find yourself from about seven o'clock on just by herself eating your,
you know,
your 28th dinner by yourself and,
um,
uh,
so that gets kind of lonely and,
if,
if my wife can't be there,
but I had my dog shipped out last
the last series,
so that was kind of cool.
Um,
but I love London.
Yes.
Dammit.
Here Allen.
Now I here hear a question.
Yeah.
Um,
you mentioned that Meredith was hard to cast,
but we're going,
the other characters in the movie,
each one seems so unique and so different from everyone else.
Regarding casting.
Did you have,
did you have anyone,
any actors in mind for the characters or did you know one lead to the other?
Um,
I had,
uh,
early on,
um,
I was,
I don't,
I'm not sure if I had anybody as I was writing it.
I think Derek waters popped into my head is Larson,
uh,
pretty early on.
And then,
uh,
I think maybe when I was doing a second draft or third draft,
I thought of James a dummy and early on,
um,
and I thought of,
uh,
Matt Walsh after doing a show with him and Improv show in which he ended up
doing the scene that was really pointed.
It turned into a very real grounded,
pointed thing.
And it was like,
that's my Dave stupid.
Um,
so,
and I think comics get a
short shrift,
um,
in being cast in regular dramatic parts.
I mean,
I,
Amy's not funny at all,
but,
and I mean the movie and Karen,
Amy,
you can do it and it,
and you're great and you,
I believe you.
And,
uh,
and I feel that way about everybody in the film there.
I believed them.
You know,
that was my next question.
If you had to like convince anyone to do it or if anyone was like David Cross,
who's this Schmuck,
I don't want to work with him.
Well,
I wasn't going after 90 year old bud billion.
Nobody said WHO's this schmuck?
But,
uh,
um,
I didn't know people still use that word because
I don't think,
I mean,
well,
there was the girl who I did it,
I
know who I knew through a friend,
um,
who bailed on the,
the one it was going to be Caitlin.
Um,
I won't say her name,
but uh,
uh,
outside of that,
everybody,
yeah,
everybody kind of jumped at it,
like really went out of their way to make it work too.
Like a lot of the people who came in from La,
we're,
you know,
we're good enough to figure out their schedule.
So I didn't have a problem with anybody.
Really.
Thanks.
Yes,
sir.
Hi.
Uh,
this is a question for Amy.
Um,
I,
yes,
I love your work.
Um,
I'm curious,
uh,
if you could talk at all about,
projects you're currently working on or future projects you're looking at.
Um,
and I was wondering specifically,
are you going to be working at all with Stephen Colbert in the future?
Uh,
with his,
uh,
upcoming new show?
Hey,
I know called bear has asked me to be a guest on the show already,
which is fine.
I'm looking for,
I think Steven's going to be great.
Everything's Steven does is great.
I'm going to Miss Letterman and I missed the Colbert report,
you know.
Um,
and right now Paul Danella and I are working on a writing project and I'm trying
to have a baby.
Just kidding.
Usually that people grow up.
Got this new wig made for myself.
Crystal.
He'd be the wings on the heart.
She holler.
I flew to North Carolina a scoliotic so that you can get a baby.
Yeah,
the Heather lawless wig that she wore in the Archie all are,
but it's got more bald spots on it.
It's Denise and I paid $3,000 for it and I can't wait to bring it alive.
I mean,
I go to bed like this thinking,
okay,
who is this woman going to be?
I can't do Heather's character.
So,
um,
I'm just obsessed with,
and I'm just,
it's just something for myself.
It sounds queer to say I'm going to go play and my wig,
but that's what I'm going to do.
But that's awesome.
Come up with characters and start figuring out who they are and what,
yeah,
that's,
I love nothing more than that.
So yeah,
I do.
I do the same thing with bud plugs.
So tell me
about,
I get a new one in the mail and I'm like,
who is this guy?
Three dimensional.
Yeah.
Flood characters.
The grounded
thank you also for Amy.
Um,
yeah,
it basically asks the same question.
I loved your work with Stephen Colbert and Paul Denelle,
strangers with candy.
Um,
were any of your lines a improvised
cause?
He said some crazy things like it's hard to,
because not everybody provisors so it's hard when you're in a scene with
somebody who does and they're scared to death if you change the script,
you know,
but we left some wiggle room for that.
And when we were writing it,
we certainly did.
We'd sit around and then we'd get up on our feet like the,
uh,
the,
the cafeteria scene where I first meet little nut,
you know,
when I like you take you take care of my baby.
Um,
we were up til three 30,
four o'clock in the morning and improvising that scene because we had no idea
where that episode was going to go.
And David Cross,
you did an episode and um,
we were,
uh,
lamb blood had to get thrown in my face.
It was so hard not to laugh at him.
And then I knew that blood was coming and I only was going to have two chances
cause I'm cause I'm wardrobe.
But that show was a blast because there's nobody who's in charge.
We were in the woods doing a show that nobody,
you know,
it was like five 30,
Sunday.
I mean,
knew,
know what he was going to watch that.
So,
and we didn't know we had fans till we did Wigfield and then all the ugly people
came out and we were like,
who are these people?
And we were like,
oh my God,
there's a stranger new candy.
They know,
and that's when we noticed that,
you know,
we had followers.
Okay.
I'm happy with that kind of audience.
The uglier,
the better.
That's great.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Thanks.
Yes.
Hi.
I have a one quick question for each of you.
Um,
to David,
one of my favorite movies of yours is run money run.
I was just wondering if there's any chance for a sequel.
I mean,
if we did that character as a 50 year old,
uh,
I,
we're left running.
Okay.
Uh,
I,
I would,
I would love to get the chance to do that idea.
Right.
Um,
uh,
you know,
we,
there's,
we talked about a lot,
but that movie was not what we intended and it,
it got cut together in a completely different way.
And,
uh,
then we had a desired,
but,
um,
I don't think,
I mean it's a fun character do and it kind of comes from like early stand up
that just from growing up in Georgia.
But,
uh,
I just,
I think maybe I'll do an older version of a,
I dunno,
there'll be role whiny role in his wheelchair.
Okay.
Um,
and then to Amy,
I love your work on broad city.
Um,
and I just wanted to hear a little bit about kind of how you work with,
um,
Alana and Abby.
And that was a blast.
I went to,
I wear a size five shoe and I went to wardrobe and they handed me size nine.
I was like,
perfect.
I totally knew what the show was going to be,
you know,
so I had a word tube socks,
but that was a character I've been working on for a while.
So it was a nice,
you know,
I kind of got to use it a little bit on that show and that there was a lot of
Improv with those girls are really still a really,
really funny.
I that was a great,
great time.
That needs to be watching the new episodes in the season.
Yeah.
Hilarious.
Yeah,
that was funny.
Size nine shoe.
Yes.
So,
uh,
I think a lot of New Yorkers go and try and do Improv,
like situational Improv and kind of casual way and you can go watch shows
everywhere.
It's like sort of an entry point,
but it seems like such a big step to improvise as a character.
You really understand and be consistent.
And that wig anecdote really like sparked my imagination of how you're figuring
out who these people are and getting ready to improvise,
particularly.
And this applies,
I think for both of you guys.
Is there a certain process you have when you're figuring out who someone is so
that you can be spontaneous about that as opposed to,
you know,
a more,
a predetermined character?
Well,
I feel comfortable if I have a mole or a hump or a wig.
And I know people say,
Oh,
you're just hiding behind that.
And I'm like,
okay,
that's fine that I'm hiding behind it,
but I just feel like I need to feel something different.
You know what I mean?
Just something to give me a little hook.
Uh,
when I just look like myself or yet improvising,
he'll,
you know,
it just doesn't,
it's not,
it's not as fun for me.
So I prefer to have,
that's why I like English shows,
you know?
I mean,
I know those,
the real teeth,
but you know,
I like how broad they can be and really put it out there.
But for me personally,
and it helps if I have a little something,
it does,
you know,
unusual like a mold or a hump or wig or something like that,
that to Sarah and scar or anything.
I mean,
I posted it.
I feel like the place,
I know it's there.
I know that butt plug is in me.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean I would concur that it's,
he,
it's um,
putting on any kind of accoutrement uh,
gives you an idea.
Um,
I remember when,
when Bob and I were starting to write Mr Show and there was a,
we were in,
uh,
this,
the shitty offices,
tiny,
tiny little shitty offices in Hollywood.
And in one of the drawers somebody had left,
uh,
the hat,
which was a cap with a ponytail,
like sewn onto it.
So He'd put on the cap and that became grass valley.
Greg,
there was no concept prior to that to putting on this hat.
Go and look at this thing.
It was like a bad sketch about a bad improv group,
taken hats out.
And then,
uh,
but we just started playing around with that and that became grass valley Greg
and then built this idea around it.
Um,
but he also looked like the guys I lived in Cambridge for a little while and um,
all those kind of molecular biology guys who brew their own beer and ride those
recumbent bikes to work and um,
he looked like that guy too.
Anyway,
uh,
I hope that answered your question.
Planes
straight like when you were in law and order or even boss,
because you're funny.
It's like Bill Murray,
you know your niche,
you want to laugh even though they're playing perfectly straight,
but you're just so good at that.
And I always think about you when I have to play something straight and you
just,
you just do it.
And,
but yet,
you know,
he's still want to laugh at you,
but you're really good at just playing completely straight.
I've got a funny face.
Yeah,
no it not your face,
just the energy you put behind it or something,
then it's good.
Yes.
So the guy in the beard
to continue in the Mr show vein,
I just wanted to let you know that I'm out of every DVD,
blue ray.
Anything I've ever owned,
nothing has more watchable factor to it than that does.
I've,
I've seen that probably hundreds of times.
I just wanted to let you know that,
uh,
what's this law and order,
Ms Mr Show?
Oh yeah.
So good break.
Cause I have
DVD of the uh,
NBC nightly news from August 14th,
19 that I,
I have watched a million.
Yeah.
Think of it.
There's a price of milk rose cause it's something had happened in Korea.
But,
uh,
what do you,
do you,
I sorry if I missed this.
Uh,
I came a little bit late,
but do you do any work with Bob Anymore?
Yeah,
uh,
um,
Bob and I over the years have,
have done,
we've done some benefit stuff,
uh,
and we will write sketches for that.
And,
uh,
and we,
did a Mr Show tour and then we did put out a book last year,
two years,
something year and a half ago,
which was a compilation of a couple of movie scripts.
And then other sketches that we wrote that never made it,
um,
uh,
in part because run running run was such a dismal failure.
And so we had these and we were like,
we're never going to make,
these were never going to get a chance to make them,
you know,
these are,
these are made written by and meant to start,
you know,
the guys in their early thirties,
and it's just not who we are anymore.
And,
and rather than just keeping,
you know,
staying on the shelf,
uh,
we put those out.
So we toured behind that.
Um,
and this is just last year,
a year,
what?
It was like a year.
Wait,
what is it now?
It's a 24,
2015,
but I'd be,
okay.
So,
uh,
it was like a year and four months ago,
something like that.
Sorry.
I Ms. Wall of not,
I,
I can't Google it.
Um,
uh,
and,
and we,
we have a master number of sketches that,
that we'd like people to see and,
and we knew that the 20th anniversary of the first year Mr Show was coming up.
So,
um,
you know,
we,
we are,
we're in talks about doing it and we will do something.
I promise.
I know it's,
it's a,
I don't,
not to jinx it,
but it's going to happen.
So we've been getting together.
I leave for la on Sunday and I'm going to be there.
I mean this is all,
you know,
we're ready to go and uh,
I'm not back home until mid July cause I got to go straight to London as soon as
we're done there.
Tip for a tod Margaret.
So,
um,
I'll miss you all.
I think how the city has grown and changed.
Um,
but yeah,
at least Sunday for La and we'll be there working on it.
Cool.
Well please pass my compliments along to Bob as well.
Just has to compliments on the bottom as well.
I'll make sure you guys absolutely.
Yes.
Hi.
Yeah,
thanks for coming.
We have such,
um,
two days in a row now.
Really funny people that are also associated with UCB.
Dick Cavett was here.
Yeah.
And,
um,
so there are a ton of people that go through UCB for classes,
which means there are a lot of people who love Improv and love to be funny.
And uh,
those classes fill up really quickly.
And I wonder if there is a site linkedin already for business people where we
connect and we sometimes have mentors that we reach out to or we connect this
improv people in some way or other.
These are not the Improv people.
So I'm imagining that Improv people have their own way of reaching out and
networking.
And I wonder if you can give us some inside insights into maybe if you are a
mentor for others or if others are mentors for you.
I know I you're talking about,
um,
I think this is right.
There's the third Barstill from the left counting as you walk in the door of
McManus McManus tavern.
There's always notes left under there.
That's,
that's,
I mean it's a little archaic
can it's old school,
but that's how improv people connect with each other.
And then they'll say,
yeah,
even though
they're not tech savvy at all.
Uh,
uh,
and I,
I truly didn't understand that.
Well,
yeah,
sorry,
sorry.
It probably was not a question.
Um,
so the question is,
uh,
do you find time to mentor others and how do you connect with those people and
do other people also become your mentors?
Is it like this official thing,
Sheryl Sandberg's book?
It's like,
don't ask for a mentor,
but then a Google,
they're like,
ask for a mentor cause they'll help,
you know,
I think lesson learned is don't trust Google.
Well not officially.
I don't know of people who really,
I mean,
I'm sure there are some who kind of,
uh,
more,
in a,
in a structured way,
mentor somebody.
But I,
I don't know of anybody off hand.
Uh,
uh,
I'm trying to raise my wife and that's a difficult thing to do.
Um,
and,
and guide her through this world.
It's a full time job.
It is.
And,
uh,
um,
but I don't,
I don't really do that.
I mean in the,
I mean,
look,
we,
we all help people along and that's one,
one of the great,
uh,
um,
unspoken things,
you know,
uh,
or underappreciated things about comics in this industry and comic actors and,
you know,
uh,
we all bring people up and a I'm,
and,
and encouraged other people to hire them and work with them and take people who
you know,
deserve a chance.
You know,
I,
I got my start on writing on the Ben Stiller show.
I was a guy in Boston,
nobody had heard of.
And,
uh,
and that's where I bet Bob Actually,
and,
um,
you know,
so I wouldn't be here if it wasn't for Janeane Garofalo Ben Stiller and Judd
Apatow.
I wouldn't be sitting here.
And,
um,
I saw tenacious d at a,
uh,
a place called a Al's bar and something called no talent night in downtown la a
long time ago,
you know,
brought them into like said,
hey,
I'm doing these series of shows.
So,
and then they in turn brought people in and,
um,
and Bob,
uh,
are,
is,
is very responsible for,
uh,
Tim and Eric being on the air and,
and Tim and Eric and burn.
I mean,
that's just how it works.
And it's a,
it's a great part of this business and there's not a lot of,
um,
or certainly less than in other industries.
I think less ego,
more cooperative.
Uh,
you know,
it's,
you served the greater good for the,
the product and the thing and the art.
And,
uh,
and that's one of the great things about,
you know,
this comic community committee community.
Great.
Thanks.
All right guys,
thank you so much for being here.
It's been a pleasure guys have,
if you haven't already,
be sure to checkout hits on a bit torrent.
It's pay what you want and,
or in theaters around the country.
You guys,
thank you so much for being here.
All right,
man.
Thank [inaudible].